hi i'm chris i'm here at the
experimental greenhouse at crop king in
lodi ohio to talk about hydroponics and
not just hydroponics we've covered the
process of hydroponics in previous
episodes but i want to talk to you now
about what can you grow hydroponically
that means what can we grow with just
water nutrients in the absence of dirt
and the answer is going to be almost
anything so we're in the lettuce house
right now but there's so much going on
here in addition to lettuce including
the varieties of lettuce we have iceberg
romaine we talked about the desktop nft
system and that's what we're using here
not the desktop but the nft or nutrient
film technique and from seed to harvest
we're talking six weeks let's talk about
some other things in addition to lettuce
that we can grow hydroponically
all right so we're here at the crop king
tomato house obviously one of the things
that are the predominant crop in here is
tomatoes these
are vine crops those are most of the
crops that we'll be looking at today and
you'll see that they are supported with
these this twine
um
to kind of make sure that they don't
snap or break under the weight of the
bearing the fruit that they're bearing
but they grow so well in here it's a
controlled environment it is a little
bright hence the sunglasses i'm not
trying to be too cool here for the video
but i am trying to make sure i'm not
looking at you squinting the whole time
but tomatoes are a huge crop here at
crop king
they're beautiful it's everything is
just uh absolutely gorgeous and you see
coming up behind me uh my sidekick jimmy
here hi jimmy to see what you're doing
oh well we're talking about all the cool
things that we grow here in the in the
tomato house it's unbelievable i just
walk them back through there yeah why
don't you go head back there and see uh
i thought i heard something fall over
there are you checking out time to hang
out for a little bit well see what
happened over there we'll be right back
yeah sure all right friends so we're
gonna take a walk down this aisle here
taking a look at some of the other crops
other than tomatoes that we grow here at
crop canyon
if you thought that you could not grow
melons hydroponically you are wrong we
have this gorgeous
vine of what looks to be cantaloupe i'm
not showing you the exact variety man do
they produce look at this
this is straight off of this vine i
can't figure out how to tell if a
melon is ripe or not so viewers if you
have a tip or trick to you got to look
for to determine if a melon is ripe
other than just cutting it open well
we'd love to hear from you
thump on it so we've talked about
tomatoes we've talked about melons
we're going to go down a little bit
farther to get into some other
produce that we're growing here and
we're also going to talk about the
manner in which we grow these we talked
about the lettuce and the nutrient film
technique that they use but these vining
crops use a little bit different
technique same principle we're using
water and nutrients to grow
but it's just a little bit different as
far as how we grow them
we're continuing our tour of the crop
king tomato house just to explore all
the different kind of vine crops we can
grow here hydroponically and i want to
talk a little bit about the system that
we use so nft systems are great for your
leafy vegetables herbs things like that
but over here we use what's called a
beto bucket or you might have heard it
as a dutch bucket system to grow our
crops that's the system that we use to
grow our vine crops versus the nft
system that is used for a lot of our
leafy crops and herbs and things like
that
the big difference is just the growing
medium that the plants are
are in so with these vine crops we want
to give it enough room to get a nice big
root and that's going to take place
inside this bucket that is filled with
the growing medium perlite
so perlite basically there's no
nutrients in perlite whatsoever it's
just basically
the medium that we use to allow the
plants to root and become stable but
plants here get so big that we still
have to use a support string to hold
them up
so the way this works we know our nft
system our nutrient film technique pumps
water in
it runs a small stream down the middle
of a channel that the roots sit down in
and it pulls out the nutrients with the
beto system
we pump water in using these drip spikes
the water then will be recirculated as
it comes down out of this channel
back into our recirculation pump and it
comes back through again so we don't
waste any water here in this system but
you can see what we can produce using
the bato system
these cucumbers are absolutely enormous
not only the the fruit itself and
hopefully you can
take a look at this one here that's not
too far off but just the height of the
plant alone
so i'm 5 10 reaching up to the tips of
my fingers and still i'm probably i
guess two and a half three feet away
from the top of this plant
[Music]
we've talked about growing in a
controlled environment such as the
tomato house here at crop king
we can control the amount of water the
amount of nutrients
and the temperatures to a certain degree
which is great by being indoors we can
grow
you know almost year round really extend
our growing season but one question that
comes up is well how do you pollinate
your plants
that's a great question now as a
an educator i have a hydroponics farm in
my school
and unfortunately my superintendent
won't let me have bees
in the cafeteria where our garden is
located why not well jim it's just a
safety concern i do believe it's
probably the best decision
but here at crop king we solve this by
these little natural pollinators right
here they're bumble bees
pretty uh pretty tame
they fly around the greenhouse here they
pretty much leave you alone but because
i'm not allowed to have bees i still
need a way to pollinate my plants
indoors and that's where this little
tool comes in this is called the veggie
bee and hopefully this will pick up on
our mic
it basically vibrates and all i would do
here is i would touch this to the flower
of my plant and this will help pollinate
it so essentially
we're getting the uh by vibrating we're
just disturbing the plant enough to
jostle loose that pollen uh to get it on
to the uh the plant that needs to
pollinate and uh by golly we're gonna
have fruit here before long prior to
this i use an electric toothbrush
because again this is the vibration
that's going to jostle loose that pollen
and get our fruit growing so this is
important because
if you're growing tomatoes and you do
not self pollinate them you're just
going to have some pretty little tomato
flowers and no fruit so you got to go
the extra step and pollinate those and
you'll appreciate the fact whether
you're indoors or outdoors this can
increase your yield incredibly
[Music]
all right well thank you for joining me
in the crop king tomato greenhouse to
explore all the things you can grow
hydroponically this is what's cool about
hydroponics and this is why i love
having it in my school you can try
anything you don't have to you're not
dependent on the growing season you can
try
just throwing seeds in and see what
happens
you'd be amazing the different things
you can grow hydroponically and
just how well it does
regardless of the season i've done
sunflowers i've done peppers cabbage i
mean the list goes on and on and that's
part of the fun is planting a seed and
see what you can do with it
hydroponically friends go out there
explore
hi jimmy
do your thing hydroponically nothing's
holding you back
hope you enjoyed this
[Music]
you